[Musique]
c'est dans son proche
tire voici enfin parmi nous ne tardons
pas
[Musique]
nous livrons bataille pour la cause dont
vous êtes la souveraine ici sur la terre
j'avais pas vu un OVNI
sont attachants c'est pour cela que nous
allons envahir la terre tout entière
le prince des ténèbres doit être enlevé
de la surface de la Terre celui qui
touche un autre crédit il y a deux cas
dans sa gueule l'entreprise
la gendarmerie sur le coup mais les
humains jaunis sont nuls faites
attention à ce que vous dites vous
adressez quand même à la gendarmerie
nationale
surtout pas peur des hommes
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça c'est une belle bande de
losers c'est peu de le dire qu'on s'en
prendre plein la gueule
[Musique]